what is left of harvey is moving toward
arkansas and mississippi right now the
storm killed at least 29 people about 50
000 homes in texas have been hit by
flooding or other damage rising water
forced new rescues yesterday east of
houston boats and helicopters were used
to help people in cities like beaumont
and port arthur beaumont's water supply
was knocked out overnight and there's a
critical need for shelter in orange
texas near the louisiana border michelle
miller is there with the story of a
church that has too many people and not
enough help michelle good morning
good morning more about that church
later i want you to see this it wasn't
just rain that that those outer bands
produced but
power power excuse me wind and the high
winds of 40 miles an hour knock down
trees and power lines like this
clearing out any electricity for the
folks here but the biggest challenge
remains
flood water several feet of it and we
should note this there's all kinds of
debris and chemicals and
critters like snakes we have seen them
floating around out
here makes these residential
neighborhoods simply look like bayou
backland
it was like a storm i never heard before
in my life flood waters forced veronica
sam and her family from their orange
texas home the small community of less
than 20 thousand is struggling to
recover from harvey's impact with
limited resources the north orange
baptist church is one of two operating
shelters in town church pastor rusty
dollar says they're at triple capacity
with nearly 400 people crammed inside
the cool thing is people come together
to show love and
our challenges we just don't have the
resources where do all these people go
then i don't know
we've talked about some people like
trying to bring in buses to help take
them to other shelters what other
shelters we don't know we have a lot of
good people here wanting to help and a
lot of people here needing a place to
stay
and you can just see the heartbreak in
people's eyes going where do i go and
i'm like i don't know
we've been working since 5 30 this
morning
caretakers and volunteers worked
together to evacuate dozens of people
stranded at an assisted living home we
got you to a good place now we're going
to get you out of the weather okay and
brought them to the church i'm just
trying to do what i can to help these
people
you know it's total devastation
my heart just
i just gotta hold together so i can help
these people
the one thing folks here don't need any
more of is rain and while it's bone dry
now
more rain is forecast margaret michelle
thank you yeah you never think about
what he was just saying i'm just trying
to help them but i never thought until
our reporting about snakes and
alligators in the water oh you're
thinking you're just trying to survive
and now you have to deal with that too
and apparently they're everywhere yeah
treacherous escape if you're going to
make one at all